[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el pasado 24 de junio al menos 23
personas en su mayoría solicitantes de
asilo sudaneses fallecieron en la parte
marroquí de la frontera con el enclave
español de melilla los hechos ocurrieron
en medio de un operativo policial de las
autoridades de españa y marruecos según
la versión policial estas personas
murieron asfixiadas tras intentar saltar
las vallas fronterizas y enfrentarse con
los agentes pero las imágenes difundidas
de los hechos muestran que los efectivos
marroquíes emplearon la fuerza contra
migrantes y refugiados desde ambos lados
de la frontera comunidades migrantes y
defensoras de derechos humanos denuncian
la represión policial y piden justicia
el informe de nuestra corresponsal sofía
catalán
estos jóvenes son supervivientes de la
reciente masacre policial en la frontera
de melilla
ellos lograron entrar al enclave español
desde marruecos para pedir asilo hoy
protestan reivindicando justicia y
guardan un minuto de silencio por los
que ya no están hussein es el portavoz
exige públicamente al gobierno español
que respete los derechos humanos
y apelamos al gobierno de españa porque
no respeta los derechos humanos
no podemos entender que aplaudan y
disfrute enviando cadáveres de la
tragedia aconteció el 24 de junio en
este lugar en la parte marroquí de la
frontera según la versión policial los
migrantes murieron asfixiados en una
avalancha tras enfrentarse con los
agentes sin embargo en estas imágenes
que difundió la asociación de derechos
humanos de nador se ve como la policía
marroquí carga brutalmente contra los
migrantes que llegaron a permanecer
horas sin atención médica los cuerpos
sin identificar de las víctimas serán
enterrados en este cementerio las
autoridades no permiten filmar en el
interior a omar es defensor de derechos
monitorea la frontera e informa a las
familias de las víctimas hoy
responsabiliza de las muertes a la unión
europea que paga a marruecos para que
impida a migrantes y refugiados
aplicarse a la frontera
la unión europea es quien financia toda
esta política migratoria
toda la política migratoria de españa
marruecos y la represión hacia los
migrantes para alejarlos de la frontera
es responsabilidad europea
es el caso de este joven que teme
revelar su identidad cuenta que
sobrevivió a la violencia policial y
llegó a melilla pero después le
devolvieron a marruecos y le trasladaron
de forma forzada a más de 800 kilómetros
de la frontera dominantes la policía
española me retuvo me pegó y luego me
entregaron a la policía de marruecos que
me sacó a la parte marroquí después vi
cómo iban sacando el resto de personas y
nos pegaban y nos decían mueran se
mueran sí juro por dios que la gente no
murió asfixia murió a palizada
con la certeza de que no habrá
investigación judicial miles de
migrantes y refugiados como este joven
seguirán luchando por su derecho a la
vida a pesar de la muerte infligidas en
las fronteras europeas
la situación es igual tensa a kilómetros
de allí en el también enclave español de
ceuta las protestas se reportan en el
día a día durante las últimas semanas el
enclave reabrió tras más de dos años
cerrado pero una nueva normativa impide
el acceso a miles de trabajadoras
transfronterizas de las localidades
marroquíes vecinas que quedaron varadas
a ambos lados tras el cierre de la
frontera sin ingresos ni prestaciones
sociales estas mujeres se exigen que se
habilite una vía de acceso para poder
regularizar su situación y reclamar sus
derechos
la frontera de ceuta vuelve a estar
abierta pero las trabajadoras marroquíes
de las ciudades vecinas ya no tienen
derecho a cruzarla sin visado son las
transfronterizas mujeres que trabajaban
en el enclave español como empleadas del
hogar
fátima hoy protesta pidiendo
reivindicación
ya en su casa explica que llevaba 15
años cruzando a ceuta para trabajar
cuando cerraron la frontera en 2020
necesitamos que abra la frontera de
ceuta y que nos dejen cruzar para poder
entrar y exigir nuestros derechos allí
hablar con nuestros jefes para que nos
re admitan o nos den lo que nos deben
como fátima hay 2500 trabajadoras ahora
españa les exige un visado de un día
para acceder a ceuta y regularizar su
situación la mayoría no lo puede
conseguir porque sus jefas les dieron de
baja en la seguridad social al otro lado
de la frontera también hay trabajadoras
paradas guardan un minuto de silencio
por las que ya no están y siguen
separadas de sus familias
como se puede entender se nos ha muerto
la hermana ángela brand y que dios la
bendiga se nos ha muerto la hermana fa
tema que dios la bendiga sus familias
están en la otra parte y no pueden ni
cruzar a ver el cuerpo ya la nosotros
las transfronterizas jamás tuvieron
derecho a paro ni ayudas ni tan solo
permiso para pernoctar en ceuta ahora
necesitan renovar su documentación para
seguir trabajando y temen cruzar a
marruecos y quedar atrapadas en el
laberinto burocrático que supone obtener
el visado nos llevamos más de 10 años
cotizando a la seguridad social y ahora
cefálico y qué va a pasar en necesitamos
un utilización que sea borrarnos para
irnos a renovar nuestros papeles que
vuelven a nuestro trabajo aquí han
avisado de un día a ambos lados de una
de las fronteras más desiguales del
mundo miles de mujeres trabajadoras
siguen esperando que se habilite una vía
para acceder a sus derechos
recordemos que marruecos se ejerce de
gendarme de ésta y otras fronteras euro
africanas como consecuencia de la
externalización de políticas migratorias
de la unión europea y es que bruselas de
la mano de españa paga cantidades
millonarias cada año a marruecos para
que impida a las personas migrantes y
refugiadas cruzar los pasos limítrofes
hasta que inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
frank 224 puntocom
[Música]